So how can Alice approach her problem
if there are lots of these communication centers?
Certainly, she can't just do a random approach and trust that she's somehow
going to find the best possible solution.
So she needs some sort of algorithm to solve her problem.
And one algorithm that would be guaranteed to find the best possible
solution, or the minimum number of devices that you need,
would be to just try all possibilities.
So, for example, if you have a very simple network, such as this one here--
Well, first of all, let's have a look at the best possible solution,
and we're going to do this as a little quiz.
So I want you to tell me where to install the monitors
so that each cable in this network is monitored.
And I want you to do this by checking off the communication centers
where we need to install monitoring devices.